so you're a multi-million dollar
chocolate manufacturer mars nestle
hershey's or whatever your name is you
sell a product that has always been in
demand from the mayans to the aztecs to
the spanish bringing hot cocoa to europe
to the advent of milk chocolate in 1876.
people went crazy for the sweet cocoa
flavor candy and by the start of the
20th century mass production of
chocolate bars had begun what started
out as an expensive indulgence reserved
only for society's elites was now a
candy enjoyed by everyone
and with mass production came the
possibility of equally massive profits
but there was just one problem coca is
expensive and its price is eating into
your margins you have to import the
beans all the way from the ivory coast
in west africa and by the time it
reaches the u.s or europe it's already
changed hands so many times that the
price is ridiculous so we need a way to
lower our costs well luckily another
industry that also gets her supply from
africa had already solved this dilemma
and was making massive profits from it
the diamond cartel
see the diamond cartel or the beers in
the 1900s controlled the diamond market
with an iron fist because they
controlled all the diamond mines in
africa and these diamond mines were
often ran with child or forced labor
they were ripe with bloodshed earning
those diamonds the nicknames conflict
diamonds or blood diamonds the result of
these low-wage diamond mines insane
profits unimaginable wealth
so all you gotta do is take a lesson out
of their handbook but instead of
harvesting blood diamonds you harvest
blood chocolates coca made off of the
backs of questionable labor so that you
can make a fortune off of the world's
insatiable lust for chocolates yes today
the world consumes 7.7 million metric
tons of chocolate a year with around
half of that being in europe that's over
200 billion dollars in chocolates the
chocolate business is as big as the
country of greece but while first world
kids are enjoying their sweet snacks
third world children are having a
completely different experience with the
chocolate industry
millions millions of children yes
working as slaves work in a slave this
is blood chocolates how the world's
favorite candy is rooted in forced labor
i'll be whatever you want me to be
milky way bars for instance are made the
milky way with gallons and gallons of
whole grade a milk fluffy whites of
cackle fresh eggs
the world's finest pure milk chocolate
all to make every bite a luscious chewy
treat
real satisfaction that's what you buy
candy
they've never tasted the chocolate their
work produces
they have no idea of the billions of
dollars made each year he earns no wages
for his work he says just food the
occasional tip from the owner and the
torn clothes on his back
[Applause]
kids some as young as 10 are fueling a
child labor movement in the cocoa fields
of western africa but you might be
surprised to learn that nearly every
time you take a bite of that delicious
sweetness you have the hands of a
child's slave to thank
nearly two-thirds of the world's cocoa
production comes from west africa where
an estimated 1.6 million children work
illegally on farms across the region
there is almost nothing that children
love more than chocolate but there are
some kids who are forced to make it
bosco and milk
just a little stirring bosco's got
plenty of vitamin d too
oh boy a basketball milk party getting
lost it's your fun what's going on here
don't worry i say some basketball milk
for you too
chocolate is a combination of cocoa
butter or powder sugar milk and other
ingredients most of the cocoa beans used
to make cocoa butter or powder come from
africa specifically the ivory coast a
nation off of the west coast of africa
up to 41 percent of the world's coca
comes from the ivory coast and companies
like nestle and mars buy most of the
supply but it wasn't always like this
before the mass production of coco
started companies like you were paying
good money for coca which obviously left
you with less profits
so you and the other chocolate companies
came together allegedly and an unspoken
agreement was entered into an unspoken
agreement that set a new standard price
for coca beans so that every
multi-billion dollar chocolate company
paid the same price for cocoa beans no
higher no lower this meant that coca
farmers no longer had the luxury of
selling coca to the highest bidder by
banning together these chocolate
companies can make sure they will all
collectively push the price of coca down
as much as possible upping the profits
and squeezing the farmers for all they
have or in other words a cartel was
formed
here's how it works today most big
chocolate companies don't actually buy
their coca straight from the farmers
instead farmers sell one kilogram of
dried cocoa beans to an intermediary for
around one dollar these intermediaries
collect cocoa beans from the farmers in
the region they wash and pack them and
then resell the coca to national
exporters this time for around two
dollars and ninety cents the beans are
transported all over the world and then
sell the chocolate manufacturers at just
over three dollars a kilogram as a
chocolate manufacturer you turn every
one kilogram of cocoa beans into around
40 chocolate bars depending on how much
cocoa they have in them that means even
if you sold these chocolate bars at one
dollar each you still be making a profit
of around 15 per kilogram of cocoa beans
depending on what else you put in the
candy of course in an industry where
around 1.3 billion kilograms of
chocolate are eaten in america alone
that's already worth at least 21 billion
dollars in profits the cartel is working
all at the cost of the coca farmer's
livelihoods in 2014 global chocolate
sales reach 100 billion dollars with
most coca farmers making around 1.25
cents a day when you do the math
manufacturers walk away with a sweet 35
of the total value for every ton of coca
while cocoa farmers they only receive
6.6
because farmers are being paid just
enough to stay under the poverty line
farmers have to resort to looking for
cheaper sources of labor in order to
survive so they turn to kids
[Music]
why haven't you heard of this dark side
of chocolate before because these
chocolate companies know the importance
of branding it's the reason why you
don't even need to read the name kitkat
or eminem to know what's inside their
packaging the designs are so iconic and
recognizable all over the world however
making beautiful designs that make you
money can be really difficult and
expensive luckily today there's a
one-stop shop for all your graphic
design and branding needs and that
one-stop shop is canva today's video
sponsor canva allows you to make these
amazing professional looking instagram
stories youtube thumbnails youtube intro
animations slide decks desktop
wallpapers infographics and even
full-blown videos it's honestly pretty
insane how much you can do canva has
thousands of easy to use customizable
templates made by professional designers
stuff that actually looks shockingly
good it's super intuitive to use you can
work on mobile or desktop canva
basically makes it impossible for you to
design something ugly you can even use
canva right now for free but you really
want to get canva pro because you just
get so many more features including
millions upon millions of assets and
almost double the amount of customizable
templates one of my favorites is their
one-click background remover something
that is notoriously tedious and
time-consuming to do but with canva you
can do it in one click another favorite
of mine is their built-in content
planner where you can make designs in
canva and then schedule those same
designs to go live on something like
instagram all within the same platform
where traditionally you'd have to pay
around the same amount for a separate
scheduling app so if you're interested
in trying out canva pro they've got you
covered with a free 45-day trial with
the link below seriously if you have a
business or an online brand canva is a
complete game changer so give it a try
for free for 45 days with the link below
[Music]
lots and lots of chocolate beans yes you
get lots and lots and lots and more
all smarties buy some food
if you are a farmer and you have no
choice but to resort to cheap or free
labor to survive what could be a better
source than kids between the ages of 10
and 14. they're less likely to escape
can't fight back can't the man raises
can't unionize and are naive enough to
believe the lies the traffickers tell
them the kids who work on plantations in
the ivory coast come from all the
neighboring countries mali burkina faso
and niger his list includes children age
seven children from mali burkina faso
and niger
these young workers are either taken by
force or for the naive ones that are
desperate for money the people bringing
them over just tell them how rich
they're gonna become on the other side
and then they comply
you get rich right
they're brought to the borders by bus
and are smoked with over on the backs of
motorcycles for each young worker
farmers pay at least 267 dollars to the
people bringing them over
once they reach the plantations the
young workers are forced to clear
vegetation spray pesticide and harvest
coca often for 12 or more hours a day
seven days a week most of them don't get
paid and for the luckiest ones the best
they can get is 85 cents a day
what this all means for you the
chocolate manufacturer is lower priced
cocoa and we're able to get away with
all this because of a little something
called plausible deniability
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
using young affordable labor to force
down the price of coca has worked out
very well but by the year 2000 the
cartel ran into a problem media reports
start flooding the world about how
chocolate companies like you are
knowingly buying coca from farms that
use young affordable labor kids some as
young as 10 are fueling a child labor
movement in the cocoa fields of western
africa but you might be surprised to
learn that nearly every time you take a
bite of that delicious sweetness you
have the hands of a child's slave to
thank nearly two-thirds of the world's
cocoa production comes from west africa
where an estimated 1.6 million children
work illegally on farms across the
region there is almost nothing that
children love more than chocolate but
there are some kids who are forced to
make it it goes so far that a u.s
senator tom harkin and representative
elliot angle even came up with a new
policy calling for the elimination of
child labor on koko farms by 2005.
but 10 years ago
horrifying evidence of child labour and
human trafficking in west africa's cocoa
fields put immense pressure on the
industry to change what i felt and i
know what elliot felt at the same time
is that we have to do something about
this this poses the first real threat to
your cartel in its entire history so
something had to be done now what you
have to understand is that the masses
are a very forgetful bunch one day
they're outraged about this and a month
later they'll be outraged about
something else so to calm them down
until they move on to the next outrage
the chocolate company signed this new
harco angle protocol to end young
affordable labor on coco farms by 2005
but since the masses will soon forget
all about this there's no rush to
actually put an end to this young
affordable labor harken and engel wanted
the industry to certify chocolate as
free from the worst forms of child
labour but the industry fought back
against the legislation what harken an
engel got wasn't a law but a voluntary
agreement by the chocolate companies to
stop exploitation as a matter of urgency
it became known as the hakken angle
protocol because you see the child labor
use on coco farms isn't your fault in
fact you have nothing to do with it at
all remember you don't actually buy your
coker from the farmers no there are at
least two middlemen between you and the
farmers which leaves us with some handy
excuses we don't know who works on the
farms how could we we're not even in
contact with the farmers it's out of our
hands
i don't know if these traffics exist and
if it exists
i presume that it is exceptional has
been a few times now in those origin
countries these are things i haven't
seen myself
but if it exists yeah okay it's clear
that it should be condemned and this is
again something which is absolutely
unacceptable
then you can do some public relations
stunts like investing a tiny 150 million
dollars out of the 200 billion market to
eradicate child labor build some schools
for even more publicity all the while
knowing that as long as koko prices stay
low these schools will be empty fast
forward to the next two deadlines and
still nothing changes which brings us to
today 20 years later where not one of
the governments has spoken out about how
chocolate manufacturers take advantage
of their people not one company has had
any of his executives find arrested or
fired
so what is the secret to getting away
with using young affordable labor i'm
only asking for a friend
[Music]
that's creamy milk chocolate
that's delicious dark chocolate
that's a layer of smooth milky bar
now put them together
that's nestle's triple bar three
wonderful tastes in one nestle's
exciting new triple bar
when the reports came out and exposed
the chocolate companies the chocolate
industry went underground suddenly
everything became a secret and no one
was allowed onto the farms where the
kids were working but that wasn't enough
it was only a matter of time before
human rights groups started to ask the
local governments too many questions and
bring up things like that international
criminal courts so to circumvent them
you beat them to the chase and go to the
local government officials yourself
allegedly see the ivory coast burkina
faso and many other west african nations
are very poor with few exports besides
coca without the taxes and fees coming
from exporting coca the government
wouldn't have enough cash to work with
which would mean the presidents and
ministers wouldn't get to enjoy their
positions of power so both you and the
local governments have similar
incentives keep the coca racket going
that's why the ivory coast first lady
allegedly had her people kidnap and kill
a journalist reporting on government
corruption in the coca industry french
canadian journalist gee andrei kifa was
kidnapped in a parking lot on the ivory
coast he was doing a story about bribery
and the laundering of coco money in the
ivorian government he has never been
found
that's why lower level ministers and
officials say this young affordable
workforce doesn't exist
so if you go now to dalawa i don't think
this still exists
so you've forced down prices you remove
yourself from any direct involvement in
child labor and you've gotten the
government on your side the only
obstacle left is the public
[Music]
you got any chocolate chocolate when you
said chocolate
full
when you buy a chocolate you get them up
full of chocolate too wow you get an
extra light chocolatey mouthful and you
bite a nestle's chocolate the only
chocolate bar whipped up so light it
fills your mouth with chocolate a
chocolate
please chocolate
you say it about food
when you buy the chocolate you get a
mouthful of chocolate too
[Music]
[Applause]
today some chocolate bars have a fair
trade label on them or a stamp that we
sustainably sourced for the consumers
that know about the young affordable
workforce in the coca industry these
labels help them justify stuffing
unhealthy sugar down their throats while
not feeling guilty about it that they're
making the world a better place by
paying a little extra for the chocolate
to be a 100 young affordable labor free
but
is it really because you and i know the
truth by now with thousands of farms and
apparently no way of knowing who works
where how can we be really sure that
these are conflict-free cocoa beans the
truth is you don't and the fair trade
label on most chocolates well they mean
as much as the heart and angle agreement
you signed in 2001 because less than 10
of the farms included in the list of
ethical farms are actually inspected by
third parties less than 10 of the farms
used to make sustainably sourced coca
have been confirmed as young affordable
labor-free and even the farms certified
by groups like the rainforest alliance
still may have children working on them
but regardless this label serves its
purpose and the masses are placated
once again it came out a little bit more
purple than i anticipated i look like an
sjw but it should fade out to a more
natural blonde and i'm not gone full sjw
just yet if you're new here we make
video essays documentaries on the most
provocative stuff in the world of money
power war and crime so if you're not
already click that subscribe button
below you have nothing to lose and
everything to gain and you can always
dislike unsubscribe and leave me your
best hate comments anytime you want if
you want more day in the life kind of
stuff you can follow me on instagram
jaketrend.io that's going to wrap it up
thank you for being part of the watch to
the end club keep sharpening that mind
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you